так Доброго дня прошу підтвердити що ми
вже наживо працюємо
Зараз ми є
Гаразд Доброго дня раді вітати вас на
спільному вебінарі Міністерства освіти
та науки України проекту search а також
українську інституту розвитку освіти
Сьогодні у нас другий вебінар перший був
Тиждень тому ми говорили про
діагностичні тести це такий спеціальний
інструмент для вчителів з української
мови Сьогодні будемо говорити про
діагностичні тести власне для вчителів з
математики
Мене звати Ольга стрилюк Я експертка з
оцінювання якості середньої освіти
проекту search модеруватиму нашу зустріч
зустріч наша триватиме годину Я коротко
представлю ідею нашого інструменту для
чого він був зроблений і який основний
його задум далі передам слово авторам
які детальніше пройдуться про по
тематиці
питання які власне
відображають наші діагностичні тести
також дадуть відповідь на на запитання
про те які закладалися теми та змістові
лінії у наші тестові завдання після того
передамо слово колегам з української
інституту розвитку освіти які
безпосередньо покажуть нам як працює
діагностичні тести як кожен учитель може
запросити учнів отримати результати І
також їх
проаналізувати і далі з ними працювати
як я вже І після того як ми завершимо з
усіма презентаціями якщо залишиться
запитання то ми матимемо час відповісти
на них Запитання Ви можете залишати у
коментарях до цього відео Крім того ми
маємо вже кілька запитань які надійшли у
попередній реєстрації Отже загалом про
суть нашого інструменту інструмент
насправді розроблявся як відповідь на
виклики з якими зіткнулася наша країна
спочатку в умовах пандемії коронавірусу
коли впродовж двох років звичний очний
процес Отже навчання були переведені в
онлайн новий формат потім ми зустрілися
як країна з набагато гіршим викликом Так
це агресії Росії проти умовний час коли
їсти на них багато хоча ви можете
залишатися
до цього відео Крім того ми маємо це
управління але має обмежені ресурси щодо
навчання Так є заклади освіти які не
функціонують через те що вони були
зруйновані інша частина
вчиться так надає освітні послуги Але у
змішаному або дистанційному форматі
лише незначна частка учнів працює в
очному форматі власне коли ми думали про
те яким чином мінімізувати втрати які
були спровоковані власне війною і
пандемією коронавірусом то думали про те
що було б дати добре додаткові
інструменти для вчителів якими вони би
могли скористатися для того щоб по-перше
зрозуміти наскільки глибокими є ці
втрати Ну і обов'язково мали би бути
поради щодо того як працювати з такими
втратами які власне
можна було виявити і
саме тому в нас постала ідея Щоб
розробити діагностичні тести як
інструмент для вчителя який він Або вона
може використати або на початку
навчального року або вже в кінці для
того щоб розуміти як ефективніше
побудувати свою роботу Я зараз
продемонструю лише один
слайд це насправді картинка з
картинка з наших діагностичних тестів
яка
розказує про логіку побудови наших
діагностичних інструментів Отже ми
пропонуємо
тестування для учнів але це не просто
виконання завдання за результатами якого
учень чи учениця отримує оцінку І
незрозуміло як далі з тою оцінкою бути
ми пропонуємо спочатку тести для
первинного діагностичного тестування які
виконуються учнями або в межах уроку або
дома це як
скаже вчитель після того як учні
виконають первинну діагностику Вони
отримують звіт звідси інформація про
фактичну рівні на якому засвоєна читачі
інше навчальна те
крім того що учні отримують звіт з
результатами своїми вони так само
отримують рекомендації до кожного
завдання яке він ще вона виконана
неправильно що таке рекомендація
рекомендація - це може бути відео на
тему З якою в учня є прогалини переважна
більшість відео є з платформи
всеукраїнської школи онлайн але є і не з
платформи зокрема за курс початкової
школи Оскільки тут такого контенту немає
крім відео Ми також пропонуємо
поправлятися із завданнями на інших
ресурсах до певних тем подаємо
інформацію з навчальних підручників
після того як учень разом з вчителем А
можливо і сам опрацює такі
рекомендації буде запропоновано вторинна
діагностичне формування вторинна
діагностика пропонує абсолютно інші
тестові завдання але повторює ті теми з
якими
учні працювали в межах первинного
діагностичного тестування станом на
сьогодні на сайті виши вже є тести для
первинної діагностики і ними можна
скористатися ми знаємо навіть що є учні
які вже скористалися І можливо теж
вчителі
завдання для вторинної діагностики
будуть
завішені на платформі вшо трохи пізніше
можливо через півтора-два місяці коли ми
все ж таки сподіваємося
учень та вчитель опрацює ці рекомендації
які буде були подані за результатами
первинної діагностики як ми створювали
тести до розробки до розробки тестових
завдань були залучені фахівці з трьох
основних
сфер які є дуже важливими для
конструювання тесту перше - це були
залучені безпосередньо вчителі які
працюють з учнями на різних рівнях
освіти і розуміють де можуть бути
проблеми і які навчальні теми краще
перевіряти наступного наступна категорія
фахівців - це фахівці з освітніх
оцінювань та вимірювань які знаються на
тому як сконструювати тест для того щоб
розрізнити учнів за різними рівнями так
тобто
початковий базовий середній та високий і
третя група фахівців - це
автори державних стандартів я Нагадую що
ми маємо зараз реформу нової української
школи і частина учнів зокрема початкової
школи а також п'ятий клас вже навчається
за новими стандартами Тобто ми
враховували цей аспект і залучили до
співпраці
таких
фахівців які розробляли на державні
стандарти і також розуміють що з
закладених
тем варто перевіряти і
[музика]
що щоби досягнути якнайкращого
результату у виконанні державного
стандарту сьогодні
ми будемо говорити про діагностику
навчальних втрат з математики як ми вже
сказали будемо говорити про тестові
завдання за курс
для 9-хласників для дев'ятикласників це
тестові завдання за курс сьомого та
восьмого класу для семикласників це
тестові завдання за курс 5 та 6 класу і
для п'ятикласників це завдання за курс
початкової школи 3-4 класу одразу скажу
що
нашими тестовими завданнями можна
скористатися як на початку навчального
року але тоді змінюється
клас в якому їх можна застосовувати якщо
що вчитель бажає застосувати на початку
навчального року То це в 5-7 та
дев'ятому класі однак скоро у нас буде
закінчення навчального року тому Наші
тести можна використовувати в четвертому
класі 6 класі а також 8 класі Разом з
тим ми зараз будемо переходити до
обговорення безпосередньо з авторами
тестових завдань
з попереднього вебінару ми засвоїли те
що окремі добірки тестових завдань
відповідають певним класам І наприклад з
української мови нам розповідала Пані
Марія блажко що можна використовувати
окрему частину тесту і в сьомому класі і
окремому восьмому класі можливо такі
самі поради нам сьогодні нададуть автори
із
математичної освітньої Галу
зараз я запрошу до слова
пані ліліано захарійченко
пані Ліліана працює в українському
центрі оцінювання якості освіти вона є
методистом відділу змісту
природничо-математичних навчальних
предметів пані Ліліана є кандидаткою
фізико-математичних наук пані Ліліана
представить нам сьогодні тест із алгебри
та геометрії
за курс 7-8 класу для
дев'ятикласників пані Ліліана Я запрошую
вас до слова і також прошу теж
зупинитися на тому що в нас є насправді
два предмети для дев'ятикласників або по
закінченню 8 класу прошу паніліана
Доброго дня Вітаю вас шановні пані та
панови дуже рада що ви долучилися до
нашого вебінару тому що дійсно питання
моніторингу освітніх втрат є дуже-дуже
важливим і ми математики це розуміємо як
ніхто тому що для того щоб йти далі нам
завжди треба розумітися що у нас є в
основі що є в базі і тому саме наше
тести
призначені для того щоб перевірити саме
базові вміння та навички які саме були
прогалини і ми дуже сподіваємось що наша
тести стануть вам у нагоді для того щоб
зосередитись перевірити які якщо це
вчитель то вчитель може перевірити які
саме проблеми є за курс ми говоримо якщо
оскільки це сьомий восьмий клас то це
вже майже закінчення середньої школи
Тобто ви розумієте що планіметрія
наприклад
фактично закінчується в дев'ятому класі
і всі основні базові вміння і навички ми
майже до 9 класу стигнемо здобути Тому
це є дуже важливим для того щоб вчитель
міг зрозуміти на що ми зосередити свою
увагу якщо для того щоб рухатись далі І
далі викладати свій предмет так само
наша тести розраховані також і на учнів
якщо Учні хочуть самі себе перевірити
хочуть подивитися які в них є
прогавини що вони не дуже добре Можливо
зрозуміли то вони також можуть
використати наші матеріали крім того Ну
як вже сказала пані Ольга то ми можемо
використовувати тести для сьомого та 8
класу не тільки на початку 9 класу також
їх можна
використовувати в кінці 9-го класу для
того щоб перевірити як засвоєні знання
для підгото для державної підсумкової
атестації яка проводиться у 9 класі
зрозуміло що ці тести не містять
матеріали за 9 клас Тому це трошки
скажемо так це вже буде як окремо крім
того наша тести також можуть бути
застосовані для перевірки знань
матеріалу які вивчаються у 7-8 класі при
підготовці до зовнішнього незалежного
оцінювання тому що пам'ятаємо що
математика вона охоплює яка на
зовнішньому незалежному оцінюванні
охоплює з 5 по 11 клас всі вміння та
навички є важливими а базові вміння є
найважливішими і вони обов'язково будуть
перевірятися
Отже переходимо з вами до
9 класу ми Я одразу ж заходжу на
платформушо обираю дев'ятий клас
детальніше
і перед нами зараз алгебра первинне
тестування оскільки
7-8 клас математика вже розгалужується
на два предмети алгебри і геометрії то
ми вважали за краще зробити окремі
добірки тобто є окрема добірка за
алгебру 7-8 клас і окремо добірка з
геометрією 7-8 клас тобто ці два
предмети є розділені
що можемо
так загально сказати про
про діагностичне тестування з алгебри
для 9-го класу воно перевіряє основні
вміння та навички які вивчались протягом
7-8 класу це Основні змістові лінії такі
як вирази
рівняння
системи рівнянь функції
і по відповідно до цих змістових ліній
ми з вами маємо завдання з наступних тем
якщо це стосується рівнянь то вивчалися
в курсі сьомому класі це лінійні
рівняння 8 класі це квадратні рівняння
Отже в добірках присутні завдання як на
лінійні так і на квадратні рівняння з
цих тем
раціональні рівняння також присутні Крім
того в кінці сьомого класу системи
лінійних рівнянь і також завдання є з
цієї теми
функції
основні функції - це лінійна функція
квадратична функція
функція оберненої пропорційності і
корінь квадратний тобто основні види
функцій які вивчають в курсі сьомого
восьмого класу
крім того до теми функції
відноситься така темати як функціональна
залежність між величинами і вміння
будувати математичну модель реальних
процесів
а також
[музика]
функції як дослідження системи лінійних
рівнянь відповідно також спирається на
графіки лінійних функцій і дослідження
цих
властивостей цих графіків крім того те
що стосується виразів то ми розглядали
цілі вирази вирази з квадратними
коренями степеневі вирази Тобто це
Степінь з цілим показником а також
раціональні вирази ірраціональні дроби
всі теми які
завдання з яких присутні наших тестах
вони
зазначені в такому якби ознайомчому
фрагменті які ви можете подивитись
прочитати ознайомитись з ним для того
щоб краще використовувати
Отже первинний
первинна діагностика з алгебри містить
завдання наступних форматів це формат
вибору вибору однієї відповіді з
чотирьох запропонованих вибору однієї
відповіді з п'яти запропонованих
завдання на встановлення відповідності
або логічні пари і також На жаль ми не
змогли
трохи обмежився формат ми не змогли
зробити завдання з короткою відповіддю
тому у нас з'являється формат завдання з
вибором відповіді однієї відповіді із
восьми запропонованих
отже за допомогою ось таких завдання
будуть присутні в тестах кожна добірка
розрахована на 30 хвилин Отже у нас є
дві первинна діагностика складається з
двох добірок перша добірка - це вирази і
функції тобто містить завдання з
змістових ліній вирази і функції друга
добірка змістить завдання з змістовою
лінією рівняння системи лінійних рівнянь
кожного з добірок розрахована на 30
хвилин і можна спочатку пройти одну з
цих довірок потім можна перейти до іншої
оскільки
після того як ви вводите відповіді ви
там вам розкажуть трошки пізніше але я
просто хочу зазначити що якщо ви зробили
помилку в якомусь завдань то за
у нас наявний фідбек і наявність цього
фідбеку дозволяє побачити яку саме
помилкове зробили а також направить вас
на посилання на підручник в якому ви
можете прочитати трохи докладніше про цю
тему порозв'язувати завдання саме з цієї
теми а також на
відео з саме з цієї теми це відео
зазвичай воно або з платформи вишиво
іноді Ми використовували інше відео
скажемо так матеріали але вони
допоможуть вам
скажемо так наздогнати цю тему Трошки її
засвоїти попрацювати над нею для того
щоб краще
впоратися із
[музика]
вторинної діагностикою яка дозволить
перевірити Наскільки Ви краще засвоїли
цей предмет
якщо я
сподіваюся Я розповіла загально те що ви
хотіли почути якщо до мене є певні
запитання будь ласка
чи можливо ще протест з геометрії кілька
слів
Так дякую я просто думала що можливо
будуть запитання саме до тесту з алгебри
чи я чи я розкажу все одразу Добре тепер
тест геометрії Значить ми повертаємось
до
9 класу
так геометрія дев'ятий клас Винники
тестування Отже геометрія перевіряє
добірка з геометрії перевіряє
основні знання та базові вміння та
навички з наступних змістових ліній це
найпростіший фігури на площині
взаємне розташування прямих на площині а
також теми що стосуються трикутника кола
чотирикутника там многокутника в межах
цих тем
вивчаються в межах цих змістових ліній
ми вивчаємо наступні теми Тобто це
елементарні геометричні фігури їх
властивості мова йде про прямі відрізки
на площині вимірювання кутів взаємне
розміщення прямих на площині і основні
властивості та теореми щодо них
відносяться
наступна тема в сьомому класі це тема
трикутники вона продовжується також і в
восьмому класі до теми трикутників
відносяться всі типи трикутників а також
властивості прямокутних трикутників
співвідношення у прямокутних трикутниках
теорема Піфагора
чотирикутники та їх елементи всі основні
види чотирикутників а також площа
чотирикутників
коло і круг
властивості кутів вписаних коло
властивості вписаних чотирикутників
трикутників
властивості
хорд Хорт кола і
тема многокутники площі многокутників
вписані описані многокутники це основні
теми які ми
навички та знання з яких ми перевіряємо
в нашій добірці з геометрії є лише одна
добірка вона розрахована також на 30
хвилин формат завдання в геометрії - це
завдання з вибором однієї відповіді з
чотирьох запропонованих і також
розмов такі оскільки не було можливості
зробити завдання з короткою відповіддю
то їх замінили завдання з вибором однієї
відповіді з 8 запропонованих і так само
як і в алгебрі після виконання завдань
первинної діагностики Ви отримаєте
фідбек які дасть вам можливість побачити
свої помилки а також
направить вас на посилання на підручники
та відеоматеріали які дозволять Вам
краще підготуватися саме з тих тем на
здолужити свої прогалини і для того щоб
краще здати вторинну для того щоб краще
скласти вторинну діагностику
якщо до мене є питання будь ласка
чи могли б ви зупинити шарення екрану
щоб ми могли з вами спілкуватися і вас
було видно
Так ви відповіли на більше запитань які
стосувалися змісту тесту тестових
завдань є два питання які насправді не
зовсім
стосується тестів але все ж таки перше
питання як уникнути списування чи
взагалі розробники якось
передбачали що учні будуть
недоброчесними і захочуть списувати чи
загалом це вас не дуже цікавило прошу Ну
будемо казати Так що Якщо
ці
ця діагностика буде проводитись в межах
уроку то вчитель скажемо так вчитель
може за цим прослідкувати так само тобто
так само як він це робить під час
контрольної роботи тобто в даному
випадку це покладається на вчителя якщо
вчитель вирішить що ця діагностика
можуть діти пройти вдома то звичайно Ну
нічого гімн не завадить скажемо так
скористатися якимось іншими довідковими
матеріалами або знов-таки передивитися
якісь відеофрагменти Ну будемо так
казати що Оскільки ми вважаємо що це
моніторинг втрат то
ми складаємо вважали що учасники будуть
так само як вчитель так і учні будуть
зацікавлені у тому щоб дізнатися про те
що вони знають а чого вони не знають як
ми ще в тому відео яке по Скажімо так
було тільки
ну яке з якими могли ознайомитись всі ті
хто хочуть скористатися нашим
інструментом то я говорила про те що Ми
планували це тестування робити як не
тестування Яке несе за собою оцінку
тобто учасник не отримає оцінку не в
журналі ні в щоденнику за виконання
цього тесту це лише моніторинг тобто він
потрібен для того щоб оцінити які знання
учасника і навички є а яких немає або
які навички треба Скажімо так
відпрацювати краще Тобто ми вважали що
оскільки
виконання цього завдання не несе ніякого
за собою покарання то можливо списування
не є Ну скажімо так А навіщо списувати
якщо Для чого Для того щоб показати що
ти щось краще знаєш тебе не будуть
карати за те що ти чогось не знаєш Я
думаю що мета вчителя якщо він буде
користуватися цим інструментом особливо
якщо він буде давати домашні завдання це
цей моніторинг то саме цей підкреслити
що не треба Якщо ви хочете щоб
ми скажемо так з вами працювали краще в
подальшому ми маємо знати на чому
зупинитися докладніше тобто
вчитель і учні зацікавлені в тому щоб не
було ніяких прогалень тому що ці вміння
знов-таки підкреслюю що ми намагалися
перевірити основні вміння та навички і
без їх знань буде складно вивчати
матеріал як 9 класу тому що це все
продовження того що було в сьомому
восьмому Ну і також в попередніх п'ятих
шостих класах і
крім того це буде подальшому коли буде
вивчення стереометрії це в геометрії і
вивчення алгебри і початки аналізу це як
продовження алгебри і тому немає ніякої
потреби бути недоброчесним тому що ви
наносите шкоду ось
Ну я б радила вчителям це пояснити дітям
що списування не є якби вони в ньому не
зацікавлені Мабуть так Дуже дякую пані
ліліано друге питання Я залишу для ваших
колег зараз Я запрошую до слова пані
Ларису пекарську вона розповість нам про
конструювання тесту з математики для
учнів
5 та 6 класу тобто за курс 5-6 класу але
це тести розрахований для учнів 7 класу
на початку він тест складався відповідно
ще до попереднього державного стандарту
Якщо я не помиляюся але пані Лариса нам
про це детальніше розповість Отже Лариса
Пекарська вчитель математики в обласному
науковому ліцеї міста Рівне крім того
пані Лариса є завідувачкою кабінету
математики та технологі технології
Рівненського обласного інституту
післядипломної педагогічної освіти пані
Ларисо прошу вас до слова Доброго дня
шановні учасники нашої зустрічі Отож
пані Ліліана розповіла про діагностичний
інструментарій для учнів та учнів
дев'ятого класу і ми будемо зараз з вами
говорити про такі інструментарій для
діагностичного тестування для здобувачів
Освіти 7 класів Отож які теми тематичні
блоки охоплює тестування для сьомого
класу
ми включили Ті теми які є найбільш
важливими в курсі 5-6 класу Оскільки ми
будемо говорити про освітні втрати Якраз
для учнів та учениць 5-6 класів і як
зазначається у навчальній програмі для
5-6 класів відповідно курс математики
5-6 класів передбачає
розвиток ізбагачення поглиблення знань
умінь навичок учнів учениць таких тем
числа та дії над ними
числові буквені вирази величини та їх
вимірювання рівняння числові нерівності
і окремі геометричні фігури на площині Я
зараз поширюю екран
Отож первинне діагностування з
математики сьомий клас
враховуючи
озвучені відповідно
теми
охоплює такі теми і так ми маємо
звичайні дроби і раціональні числа та
дії над ними оскільки в 5-6 класах
відбувається поступове розширення
поняття множення натуральних чисел то
важливими темами для того щоб розширити
поняття множини натуральних чисел її
відповідно звичайні дроби і раціональні
числа якщо ми говоримо про звичайні
дроби то завдання які ми пропонуємо
з цієї теми це звичайні дроби і ділення
натуральних чисел основна властивість
дробу скорочення дробу зведення дробів
до спільного знаменника арифметичні дії
звичайними дровами знаходження дробу від
числа і числа за його дробом Якщо ми
будемо говорити про таку тему як
раціональні числа то ми
розуміли формуючи конструюючи завдання
що це мають бути не лише завдання на дії
з раціональними числами а й завдання які
передбачають порівняння раціональних
чисел розкриття дужок зведення подібних
доданків
і
однозначно однією із
важливих змістових ліній курсу
математики
відповідно є тема рівняння така змістова
лінія рівнянь і нерівності тому
відповідно тема яку ви бачите на екрані
рівняння основні властивості рівнянь
також знайшла відображення серед
запропонованих завдань
при виконанні цих завдань учнів і
учениці будуть мати можливість
розв'язувати рівняння на основі
залежності між компонентами і
результатами арифметичних дій а також із
урахуванням основних властивостей
рівнянь
наступне важлива тема в курсі Власне
кажучи 6 класу це є тема відношення і
поділ числа у даному відношенні тому і
завершенні вивчення цієї теми наші
здобувачі освіти мають розуміти що таке
відношення і знаходити відношення чисел
і величин в навчальній програмі з
математики до цієї теми віднесено також
знаходження відсоткового відношення
чисел окрім того Якщо говорити про те ми
звичайні дроби то ми розуміємо що в
навчальній програмі до цієї теми
відносяться також ще завдання на
знаходження відсотків від числа і числа
за його відсотками як продовження
виконання знаходження дробу від числа і
числа за його дробом
зараз запропонованих завдань також
наявні завдання
які мають на меті перевірити чи
розуміють учні Що таке модуль числа і чи
ні його знаходити
істотне місце у
серед завдань відповідно у вивченні
курсу математики 5-6 класу мають
текстові задачі і текстові задачі
відповідно під час яких Наші учні
учениці
вчаться створювати математичні моделі і
розв'язувати їх такі задачі
супроводжують вивчення усіх тем
шкільного курсу математики і серед
очікуваних результатів знову ж таки які
зазначаються в навчальній програмі є
такі що учень учениця розв'язує сюжетні
задачі з реальними даними що показує
зв'язок математики з життям Отож
запропоновані ось оці текстові задачі
якраз
спрямовані на те
щоб учні учениці
могли
вчителів свою чергу чергу могли
перевірити не тільки перевірити знання
учнів але й вміння здатність їх
застосовувати Серед таких тестових
тестових задач це задачі на залежність
між величинами такими звичними швидкість
шлях і час на фінансові розрахунки на
досягнення українських спортсменів на
міжнародних змаганнях такі завдання
дозволять перевірити учня вчителям не
лише сформовані знання уміння певні
навички але допоможуть нашим здобува
життя освіти у формуванні певних
ключових компетентностей необхідних у
повсякденному житті
зміст геометричний матеріал включає
початкові відомості про планіметричний і
стереометричний фігури
важливе місце також у шкільному курсі
математики зокрема в 5-6 класах
має мають такі сформовані вміння як
здатність учнів аналізувати дані подані
у вигляді діаграм і також
будувати діаграми за наведеною
інформацією тому такі завдання також
мають місце серед запропонованих
тестових завдань
тест складається із двох частин
двохступтестів
відповідно
один субтест охоплює теми дроби
геометрія аналіз даних і другий
стоп-тест охоплює такі під теми як числа
рівняння нерівності і задачі кожен із
кожна з частин містить 9 завдань це
завдання двох видів завдання
з вибором однієї відповіді з декількох
запропонованих і завдання на
встановлення відповідності ми надіємося
що
запропоновані завдання
стануть у нагоді не лише на початку
навчального року у сьомому класі а і
відповідно їх можна буде використати і
по завершенню курсу навчання в 5-6 класі
а також під вас підготовки до державної
підсумкової атестації у 9 класі і під
час підготовки до зовнішнього
незалежного оцінювання і я ще хочу
продовжити думку пані Ліліани стосовно
того чи Наші учні будуть списувати чи не
будуть списувати Власне кажучи якщо
говорити говорити про здобувачів освіти
шостих
11-х класів
то вони звикли до того що за виконану
роботу Вони мають отримати оцінку якщо
говорити про нову українську школу і
учні учениці які уже перейшли у нас в
п'ятий клас то вони розуміють що окрім
підсумкового оцінювання яке за яке Вони
отримують оцінку є ще формувальне
оцінювання яке оці їхній
поступ у навчанні і за яких не
виставляється за які не виставляється
оцінка тобто дитина бачить сама прогрес
у своєму навчанні у своєму успіху тому
Власне кажучи Це ще один вид оцінювання
формувальне оцінювання до якого не
звикли учні 6-11 але уже звикли учні
початкової ланки і учнів 6 клас це те
оцінювання за яке немає Покарання і воно
здійснюється з цією метою щоб побачити
поступ побачити прогалини і якщо ми
говоримо про
рекомендації Міністерства освіти і науки
які вийшли у цьому році то Міністерство
освіти і науки рекомендує на початку
навчального року провести таке
діагностичне тестування з цією метою щоб
вчитель міг зорганізувати систему
створення для того щоб подолати ось оці
прогалини у знаннях і далі уже
організувати Такий процес навчання який
би дозволив ефективно і швидко
продовжувати далі процес навчання Дуже
дякую пані Ларису за представлення курсу
і так само за відповідь на попереднє
запитання але користуючись нагодою Я теж
задам ще одне запитання до вам оскільки
Ви викладаєте в школі безпосередньо Так
це ліцей можливо це трохи інший ступінь
але все ж таки в мене таке питання тобто
не моє питання А питання від наших
глядачів
коли би ви застосовували безпосередньо
тест на уроці Чи все ж таки задавали
виконати його дома з огляду навіть на те
що він має дві частини на кожну
передбачену по 30 хвилин і впродовж
одного уроку учні можуть не справитися
Які ваші рекомендації щодо цього чесно я
би його використовувала попросила би
діти щоб вони його виконали думку
спокійні обстановці тому що Власне
кажучи не знають чи будуть умови щоб
весь клас якщо він є великий
розмістити в комп'ютерних або
забезпечити технікою щоб провести ось це
тестування от і ми розуміємо що часу
кількість годин не у всіх класах
дозволяє скажімо виокремити окремий урок
а той два уроки для того щоб здійснити
це діагностування а в якості того що
виконайте домашнє завдання пройдіть один
тест одну частину тесту тому що є
можливість проходити блоками це
тестування Діти прийшли один тест
відповідно побачили свій результат і
вчитель бачить прогресу учнівський і
потім на наступний урок виконати інший
тест або дати Завдання таке достроково
ну в рамках тижня за тиждень Ви маєте
виконати ось оці дві частини чи і
отримаєте результати І далі ми будемо
планувати свою роботу і
організовувати освітній процес це таке
моє печення Дуже дякуємо пані Ларису за
таке практичне практичну пораду до
вчителів математики
Дякуємо за представлення цієї частини
далі я хочу запросити до слова пана
Андрія меляника пан Андрій є заступником
директора Львівського регіонального
центру оцінювання якості освіти також
пан Андрій долучався до розроблення
державного стандарту початкової освіти з
математики якщо я десь була некоректна
пана Андрій ви мене поправите а далі
передаю вам слово Дякую все гаразд пані
Олю все правильно я
все ж таки буду багато повторятися бо
попередній спікерки дуже докладно
розказали я спробую це зробити
такими тезами такими короткими найперше
для чого ми розробляли цей
інструментарій ми хотіли допомогти
нашим колегам нашим вчителям щоб
спробувати виявити і подолати ті втрати
які скоріше всього виникли за два роки
пандемії і рік війни і для цього ми
створили отакий інструментарій Отакі
діагностичне тестування з математики на
різних рівнях на рівнях
[музика]
5-7-9 класу
яка його структура структура того власне
інструменту там таких головних три
частини перша частина - це діагностичне
первинне діагностичне тестування після
цього є певні рекомендації що робити з
тими помилками які виникли під час
тестування і друга частина
це так би допомога в подоланні тих
втрат тих подолання виявлені тих
прогалин і третя частина - це вторинне
діагностичне тестування яке мало би
показати кращий результат ніж первинних
хоча за структурою первинної вторинним
вони абсолютно ідентичні
це одна теза стосовно того що це за
інструментарій для чого він не потрібний
що є в результаті в результаті немає
оцінки це всі вже підтвердили оцінки
оцінка нам в даному випадку Нічого не
дає нам важливо важливіше мати
рекомендації і важливіше побачити що
після вторинного в нас результати
покращилися дуже на це сподіваємося і та
ти проміжок між одним і другим
тестуванням не пройшов даремно і дуже
активно попрацювали учні активно
попрацювали вчителі і результати стали
кращими
які ми давали рекомендації
рекомендаціями як правило є покликання
на уроки всеукраїнської школи онлайн
Хоча є і покликання на окремі підручники
на окремі збірники завдань на окремі
власне параграф чи чи навіть окремі
завдання в тих підручниках
А тепер по
структуру тесту після початкової школи я
спробую розшарити екран
і про
структуру власне тих
добірок чи тих частин
ми охопили всі змістові лінії одна
змістова лінія - це є числе і вирази
Тобто ми окупили основні теми - це і
числа і дії з числами і вирази дроби
вимірювання величин рух тіл друга
змістова тема - Це є робота з даними тут
завдання значно менше Але є окремі
завдання які стосуються
як читання даних тобто просто просте
знаходження
якоїсь якихось даних в таблицях у
графіках діаграмах так і певний аналіз і
певне застосування тих даних для
розв'язання того чи іншого завдання
і геометричні величини та
геометричні фігури та величини
така змістова лінія теж У нас є охоплена
ми пробували
створити завдання на виявлення на
знаходження площі і периметра
прямокутника чи квадрата і на
класифікацію порівняння геометричних
фігур зокрема просторове геометричних
фігур таке доволі насправді не складна
задача що стосується
рівня складності то більше більшість
наших завдань це завдання початкового і
середнього рівня є частина завдань
достатнього рівня і лише одне завдання в
цілому Я говорю про початкову школу одне
завдання високого рівня коли ми говоримо
про
когнітивні рівні то ми
балансували щоб були і завдання на
знання щоб були і завдання на
застосування тих знань і щоб були
завдання на міркування тобто щоб учасник
міг показати як він вміє будувати ту чи
іншу послідовність певних певний
ланцюжок
тверджень які ведуть до певного висновку
про що варто ще сказати що
більшість завдань в
за курс початкової школи Вони
є у вигляді певних життєвих ситуацій
певно опису життєвих ситуацій щоб ну
та математика звідкись має взятися Це не
для початкової школи це давати завдання
чистої математики Ну напевно не зовсім
доцільно бо А звідки це взялося А що це
таке тому в нас дуже багато є завдань і
на моделювання
таких доволі нескладних життєвих
ситуацій і на
[музика]
І наприклад на розпізнавання певних
фігур теж з життя
тому на цьому ми робили свій окремий
акцент
і останнє про що хочу сказати І про що
коліжанки теж говорили про відповідні
стандартам і про відповідність програми
коли ми писали наш інструментарій то ми
ну однозначно заглядали в стандарти і
всі наші завдання відповідають стандарту
всі наші завдання зокрема по початковій
школі відповідають і програмі шияна і
програмі Савченко тобто у нас немає
якихось завдання які би були націлені
лише на одну з програм тому можна сміло
їх використовувати у нашому
у нашій практиці і у власного
діагностуванні того і виявлені тих втрат
і в подоланні
дякую
Дуже дякую Пане Андрію маю таке
запитання
ми коли апробовували інструмент перед
тим як запустити його на сайті
всеукраїнської школи онлайн Я розсилала
доступ до тестових завдань Своїм
знайомим в яких є діти власне або в
четвертому або в п'ятому класі переважно
в п'ятому класі і одна з мам мені
написала що вони в початковій школі не
стикалися з таким от типом завдань це
йшлося про роботу з даними Я дуже добре
про це пам'ятаю чи інші учні можуть теж
закидати той факт що вони не проходили
таких завдань чи тут Питання в тому як
викладалася математика в початковій
школі в цьому може бути причина загалом
такого
та причина причин може бути кілька так
Ну насправді мусимо Пам'ятати про два
роки пандемії і рік війни і це три роки
з чотирьох років навчання в школі ну
однозначно мають вплив на те що і як
викладалося в школі
з іншого боку тема робота з даними вона
є найменша змістова лінія в курсі школи
і їй напевно не так багато уваги
приділяють як наприклад роботі з числами
чи виразами чи з геометричними фігурами
тому я не виключаю що може бути
один з варіантів що дійсно вчителі цьому
не приділили достатньо уваги або
приділили той уваги не так багато щоб
вона так абсолютно відклалася в
голові учасника чи учасниць
але ця тема дуже важлива ця тема
ми в житті і найбільше зустрічаємо тобто
в газетах в публікаціях в
інтернеті дуже багато всяких різних
діаграм графіків які треба вміти читати
з якими треба вміти працювати які треба
вміти аналізувати і це має Ти вже і від
початкової школи завдання насправді
не хочу сказати примітивні але доволі
елементарні
тобто навіть маючи
засади здорового глузду можна доволі
спокійно
зрозуміти як в тій табличці знайти те що
треба знайти чи як за тим графіком
знайти те що питають В умові завдання
за відповідь якщо я правильно розумію То
наш інструментарій так охоплює навіть ті
змістові лінії які є дуже вузькими так і
яким можуть не приділяти достатньо уваги
в школі Але тим не менше ми включили
його в її цю змістову лінію свій
інструментарій Так І він власне дасть
змогу перевірити На якому рівні вона
засвоєна і Фактично це буде як один з
дзвіночків і вчителю і учню щодо того що
над чим треба попрацювати краще Дуже
дякую за інтерв'ю за вашу презентацію
також за відповідь на це запитання далі
ми переходимо до наших колег з
українського інституту розвитку освіти
Український інститут розвитку освіти
власне є адміністратором всеукраїнської
школи онлайн і саме з колеги з інституту
півроку тому запропонували що нам таку
співпрацю сьогодні
колеги
будуть розповідати про те як в
безпосередньо користуватися платформою
вишион і безпосередньо тим
інструментарієм який ми напрацювали пані
Ніно я хочу вам теж
зачитати запитання так яке надійшло до
нас із
реєстраційною форми чи можливо тести
проходити на іншому сайті наприклад Наш
заклад працює на всеосвіті
і чи можна їх проходити на інших
платформах Можливо ви одразу будете
відповідати на це питання але
Майте на увазі що воно цікавить наших
глядачів Отже Прошу пані Ніна сухаренко
представник чи український інституту
розвитку освіти
Доброго дня
Вітаю всіх хто приєднався
до нашого вебінару дякую пані Олю Мене
звуть Ніна Слюсаренко Я начальник
сектору освітніх ресурсів державної
установи Український інститут розвитку
освіти
Сьогодні ми з вами дізнаємося про те як
організувати комп'ютерну діагностичне
тестування яке розміщене на платформі
вшо ну власне тут можу дати одразу
відповідь власне ці тести
розміщені на платформі всеукраїнська
школа онлайн і відповідно на ній і можна
їх проходити зареєструватися може
будь-хто власне реєстрація дуже легка Я
вам зараз про це розповім І
що якби вигідно
відрізняє тести створені проектом сурчик
який я зараз ми презентуємо а тим що тут
можна виявити не тільки такі
можливі прогалини ликуни
освітні розриви дав
навчанні А одразу Буде
надана інформація
яким чином можна їх надолужити Тобто
кожна конкретна тема буде прямий
покликання на або урок всеукраїнської
школи онлайн або підручник з конкретними
сторінками як де учень чи учениця можуть
прочитати цю інформацію і власне
опрацювати
для тих хто з вчителів які зараз нас
слухають хто ще не зареєстрований на
я трошечки більше
розкажу про неї
всеукраїнська школа онлайн - це
безкоштовна освітня платформа
яка створена для дистанційного та
змішаного навчання
і на цій платформі розміщені курси для
5-7 класів
і зараз ви бачите перед собою
власне таку картинку де яким чином можна
зареєструватися
на платформі я вам це дуже раджу зробити
Зараз ми бачимо вчителя математики
можуть побачити які у нас там розміщені
предмети
і власне кожен кожен урок кожному курсі
він складається з таких трьох частин це
коротке відео
[музика]
від 5 до 15 хвилин це тести
і це
це конспект і це тести після
зараз я відкрию
А так також на цій платформі передбачено
і
[музика]
передбачено тематичне оцінювання і
підсумкове оцінювання курсу відповідно
можна буде подивитися вчителю і учнів
власне буде видно прогрес учня і це якби
дуже важливо Зараз
я вам можу показати
з чого складається
а от кожен рух ви можете побачити
От наприклад
урок математики
коротке відео перед вами
ви не бачите
Зараз одну секунду
[музика]
Так зараз видно зараз
Так я
не видно не видно
Зараз одну секунду
супер Є все А все є Да окей А Значить
тут є короткі кульки короткий так
коротке відео от зараз перед вами відео
на 7 хвилин
конспект ви можете побачити
і відповідно Да і відповідно тести тести
ідуть до кожного уроку це формувального
оцінювання але от зараз ви можете
побачити що без відповідної реєстрації
або авторизації тести не
Ви не зможете переглянути і пройти
відповідно Зараз ми можемо побачити
зараз я
[музика]
зареєструюся і ми можемо
з вами переглянути тести і так само
після кожної теми іде
тематичне підсумкове тематичне
оцінювання теж одразу після авторизації
ми з вами
зможемо їх пройти
Зараз ми з вами авторизуємося
приклад геометрія восьмий клас
відповідно ви вже тут можете бачити
завдання можете на них відповідати
що я ще на чому хотіла вашу увагу
[музика]
зараз я переключуся
А що я ще хотіла сказати що власне
станом на кінець
2022 року на платформі вже зареєстровано
понад 300 тисяч учнів і
понад
130 тисяч вчителів і десь близько 30
тисяч слухачів Так що я вас закликаю
реєструватися і в повній користатися
всіма можливостями які для нас пропонує
всеукраїнська школа онлайн Ну А далі ви
з моєю колегою Аллою ворожби дізнаєтесь
власне як створювати власний курс
первинного діагностичного тестування
ознайомитись з інструкцією тестування
учнів учениці запросите учнів учениці до
курсу і зможете переглянути звіти за
виявленими освітніми втратами
зараз я її передаю
Вітаю шановні учасники
хочу особисто подякувати особисто від
себе від українських вчителів
розробникам даного інструменту який
допоможе нам виявити певні прогалини
певні розриви у навчанні які сталися у
нас з вами за останні роки Ну і завжди
пам'ятати що тестування є надійним
способом для перевірки знань вмінь учнів
На якому рівні вони досягли
успіху Так це виявити і перевірити Отже
ну а зараз ми з вами розглянемо як
необхідно
провести тестування на платформі
всеукраїнської школи онлайн після того
як ви залогинулися на платформі ввели
логін пароль ви можете перейти у вкладку
мій кабінет
на першій вкладці інструкція вам буде
запропоновано переглянути відео
де показано більш детальна робота
безпосередньо кабінета вчителя це є
інструментом для спільної роботи з
учнями та ученицями та відстеження
їхнього прогресу у навчанні це відео
буде доступне і надалі але перший раз
там необхідно обрати Я уважно опрацював
чи опрацювала інструкція та натиснути на
кнопку розпочати після того наступним
кроком буде створення власної копії
курсу для цього вам необхідно перейти на
вкладку запросити учнів та учениць на
курс обрати клас обрати предмет
математика і відповідно
А де вони математика мене
так давайте я спробую сьомий клас
математика
первинний діагностичне тестування У мене
просто математика вже було створено
копія цього курсу тому я вже повторно не
можу цього зробити я зараз це зрозуміла
Отже ви обираєте і
натискаєте на кнопку готову Таким чином
буде відбуватися копіювання цього курсу
на платформі цей процес може зайняти
деякий час але ви можете дізнатися про
це успішне виконання коли перейде не на
вкладочку управління курсами і
відповідно ви побачите про те що я вже
один раз скопіювала математику і п'ятий
клас І наприклад алгебру дев'ятий клас
вона у мене вже є в моєму власному
кабінеті Ну а тепер безпосередньо
необхідно запросити учнів та учениць
відкриваєте запросити і в першому
віконечку де користувачі у нас під меню
панелі управління курсом ви можете через
кому ввести
Перепрошую електронні кошти ваших
користувачів дуже зручно використовувати
облікові шкільні записи які вам може
передати класний керівник або
адміністратор якщо ви наприклад будете
використовувати Google Word Space так
далі ви
вказуєте можна Перелічити через кому
якщо це спектр квадратів всього класу чи
по кілька учнів ви будете окремо
реєструвати обов'язково перевірте що у
вас натиснуто
надіслати сповіщення на електронну пошту
і натискаєте зареєструвати учнів на курс
тобто спочатку вони мають
зареєструватися на платформі а потім
вони вже зможуть прийняти запрошення для
того щоб
Пройти тестування так далі ви натискаєте
Зареєструвати і після того
ви можете їх об'єднати в класі насправді
для проведення тестування в цей момент
не впливає але якщо ви забудете потім
дивитися результати вже безпосередньо по
кожному класу то буде зручно щоб у вас
одразу вже було обраний Такий поділ для
цього ви можете натиснути кнопку додати
клас
створюєте назву ви можете писати
нам А клас я би ще рекомендувала
зазначати рік навчання тому що ви будете
робити тестування не тільки цього року
можливо і наступного що ми потім не
плутатися в 9 А класі що він у вас буде
повторюватися ну відповідно натискаєте
налаштувати вручну розподіл тому що у
нас може бути багато учнів і натискаєте
створити
після того як ви
[музика]
зараз я обернуся на презентацію після
того як ви переконалися що ваші учні
зареєструвалися на платформі
всеукраїнської школи онлайн після того
як ви переконалися що учні приєдналися
до курсу А ви зараз бачите на слайді
праворуч
фрагмент зображення яке вони отримують
на пошту щоб прийняти це запрошення
запрошення лише після того починайте
тестування з учнями
хочу звернути увагу що учні в своєму
кабінеті можуть знайти даний курс в
панелі управління він буде виглядати Ось
таким чином тобто не в курсах від
всеукраїнської школи онлайн а
безпосередньо в курсах від вчителів та
учителів саме за таких умов з
результатами зі звітом по всьому класу
ви як вчитель зможете ознайомитися тому
що в першому випадку учні так само
прийдуть тестування але лише їм буде
видно результати лише вони сформують той
звіт і звичайно можуть його вам передати
але якщо ви хочете побачити статистику
по всьому класу як в класі учнів
засвоїли ту чи іншу тему з математики
алгебри чи геометрії то ви вже Можете
саме необхідно виконати саме таким
способом Ну і відповідно учні починають
розпочинають це тестування
що стосується структури уроків уже
розробники попередньо розказали зазвичай
кожен тест складається з двох частин
кожну з них можна пройти окре тому можна
прийти разом якщо по часу вам це зручно
тестуватися Можна в межах закладу освіти
це може бути або кабінет інформатики
обладнаний достатньою кількістю
комп'ютерів або Можливо у вас є
переносні комп'ютери які можна
використати безпосередньо в класі також
можна Пройти тестування вдома саме
тестування автоматично по часу не по
часу не зафіксовано тобто воно не
обмежене але ви як вчитель маєте якщо це
в класі то самостійно стежити за часом
зафіксувати його і якщо учні будуть
виконувати вдома то те щоб вони
пам'ятали про час час який відводиться
на тестування і буде зазначений в
інструкції тобто ось ми бачимо приклад
інструкції і тут для учнів теж є певні
застереження Тобто їм пропонується
підготувати папір та ручку для того щоб
виконувати якісь обчислення необхідно
його підготуватися щоб вони не втрачали
час і не заважали в класі іншим учням
Якщо це не зроблено І після того вони
починають тестуватись
їм пропонується кілька запитань
необхідно обрати лише одну правильну
відповідь і після того обов'язково
натискати кнопку надіслати якщо
наприклад учень подумає що він обрав не
зовсім правильну відповідь і спробує
обрати іншу то необхідно повторно
натиснути кнопку надіслати для того щоб
збереглася правильно На його думку
відповідь
так після того як учні пройшли
тестування ми можемо переглянути їхні
оцінки ми перейдемо
панелі управління курсом на вкладку
оцінювання ось цей пункт під меню і
натиснемо переглянути журнал оцінок ви
побачите табличку де ліворуч зазначену
ніки наших користувачів а праворуч
зазначено їхні в другому стовпчику їхні
електронний адреси Я наприклад обираю
учня який пройшов тестування Я хочу
зазначити що це були реальні учні які
під час зимових канікул поводилися
Пройти тестування з математики тому тут
лише в мене кілька є відповідей і ось ми
бачимо результати виконання учнем який
обрав тобто має 100%. він ми бачимо те
що він отримав високий рівень знань з
цього предмету тобто немає ніяких У
нього прогалин є загальний результат
100% і є відповідно за розділами так
сам тест Уже зазначалося ми не бачимо
ніякої оцінки ми лише можемо визначити
рівень який досягнув учень у засвоєнні
того чи іншого матеріалу і більше нічого
далі Зараз я продемонструю результати
учня який
зробив уже я попросила зробити деякі
помилки свідомо для того щоб подивитися
як же буде в цьому випадку виглядати
звітність ми бачимо що допущена помилка
не вплинула сильно на результат це
знання високого рівня але внизу у нас
з'явилася Ось такі невеличкий блок де
зазначено певні програми зазначено тема
розділ точніше сказати і відповідно тема
і повідомлення що на жаль учень не
впорався в завданнями Але для того щоб
це не дожити він може ознайомитися з
матеріалами це буде відеофрагмент
всеукраїнської школи онлайн так і
підручник де зазначено номер параграфа
сторінка і відповідні вправи які йому
треба виконати для того щоб наступний
раз під час тестування
виконати подібне завдання вже правильно
і отримати
Я думаю що оцінку і таким чином
формується такі звіт Крім того ми можемо
ознайомитися зі звітом учнів
загалом для всього класу для цього
необхідно перейти в під меню
завантаження даних обрати завантажити
загальний звіт
І після того як ви натиснули у вас буде
сформований звіт у формулі форматі
електронних таблиць які ви можете
відкрити за допомогою доступного вам
програмного забезпечення на слайді я вам
покажу ось праворуч знаходиться цей
фрагмент Тобто це вже такий звіт по всім
учням класу ви не бачите конкретно Хто з
чим не впорався але ось у вас зазначені
певні теми і те що той матеріал який
необхідно опрацювати учням далі після
опрацювання цих матеріалів з учнями
індивідуально чи в групі всім класом Ви
можете пройти уже вторинний діагностичне
тестування яке буде розміщено на
платформі всеукраїнської школи онлайн як
же говорилося зараз у нас знаходяться
тести первинного первинної діагностики
для
усіма математика для учнів п'ятого та
сьомого класу і алгебри та геометрії для
учнів 9 класу
Отже Я особисто сподіваюся що цей
інструмент дозволить подолати і
невеличкий прогалини розриви у вивченні
математики алгебри та геометрії та
дозволить в справжньому вже журналі
нашим учням отримувати оцінки високого
рівня дякую
пані Алло за презентацією Я сподіваюся
що вона допомогла нашим вчителям і
слухачами принаймні частково забезпечити
цим курсом в нас власне були запитання
найбільше які стосувалися того чи можна
наприклад пройти курс не будучи
зареєстрований на платформі вшо отже і
Пані Ніна і Пані Алла підкреслили що не
можна і вчитель і учень обов'язково
мають бути зареєстровані на вшо іншим
питанням було чи може бути
зареєстрований вчитель учень не
зареєстрований або чи може учень пройти
тест самостійно який учень який вчитель
йому не надсилав цей інструмент ми
відповіла на це запитання учень
так Так дякую пані Олю так дійсно Ви
можете пройти тести на будь-яких умов
але і також Хочу наголосити якщо учень
реєструється сам без вчителя То він може
це зробити самостійно Аби з батьками то
ви Я так само як мама спробувала теж Моя
дитина проходила це тестування мені було
цікаво побачити результати Тобто ви їх
уже самостійно перевіряєте Якщо ж
вчитель сам зареєстрований а не створив
цілий клас то він сам не зможе зібрати
загальні результати по класу Якщо ж він
вбере саме в кабінеті вчителя яке щойно
показали на цей клас То вже буде
статистика по всім учням конкретного
класу і щодо того першого питання яке ви
запитували що стосується чи можливо
проходити такий тест на платформі
всеукраїнської школи онлайн Я хочу
сказати що це саме така платформа де
підготовлено навчальні матеріали пані
Ніна про це сказала і безпосередньо
тести але тести незвичайні тому що якщо
ви навіть будете копіювати питання
тестів з нашої платформи і спробувати їх
розміщати на якихось інших ресурсах в
будь-якому випадку ці платформи перед це
зазвичай оцінку в балах у нас немає
таких балів у нас результат - це теми
які треба додатково доопрацювати Тобто
ви не отримаєте Ви не зможете це
самостійно тут уже потрібні будуть
програмісти і саме Якраз для держави для
українських дітей які знаходяться у нас
в Україні і тільки знаходяться за
кордоном зараз вони можуть продовжити
навчання
Дуже дякую за це уточнення Я теж хотіла
власне закцетувати на унікальності
нашого інструменту оскільки як я раніше
казала ми пропонуємо не лише тестові
завдання бо тестових завданнях насправді
є дуже багато на різних сервісах і
ресурсах ми ж пропонуємо зворотній
зв'язок для учня учениця а також для
вчителя Тому що вчитель теж отримує звіт
і він бачить інформацію про кожного
свого учня тому скопіювати
тести на іншу платформу можна але ми ж
даємо зворотний зв'язок так у нашій і У
нього закладено дуже багато насправді
рекомендацій якими треба скористатися і
тут є унікальність цього цього сайту так
і нашого інструменту тому Закликаємо вас
користуватися
діагностичним первинним діагностичним
тестуванням яке пропонує всеукраїнська
школа онлайн
Якщо за результатами первинної
діагностики ви будете бачити недоліки
або захочете якимись чином удосконалити
або будете мати пропозиції Як
удосконалити чи тестові завдання чи
інструмент загалом То можете написати до
українського інституту розвитку освіти
або до нашого проекту ми обов'язково
спробуємо врахувати такі
ваші пропозиції Отож Нагадую що сьогодні
ми мали вебінар стосовно
діагностичного тесту з математики ми
розповідали про первинний діагностичне
тестування яке можуть застосувати
вчителі на початку
5-7 та 9 класів або наприкінці 4-6 та 8
класів Разом з тим якщо вчителі детально
ознайомляться із структурою кожного
субтесту то можливо зрозуміють як
застосувати ті тестові завдання і в
інших класах так на яких мене акцентуємо
однак де наші завдання покривають
навчальні теми крім того хочу
закцентувати на того що на тому що у нас
триває війна Наші учні переміщуються за
кордон або навпаки повертаються за
кордону іноді є така ситуація що
потрібно провести діагностику всередині
навчального року ми будемо мати новий
семестр в когось він вже розпочався і
пропонуємо теж пошукати серед наших
тестів ті навчальні теми які проходили
наприклад учні у першому семестрі і
таким чином теж застосувати їх щоб
розуміти чи потрібно додатково працювати
з новими учнями але так само можна
застосувати і
стосовно тих учнів які вчаться починаючи
з 1 вересня це певно те що ми сьогодні
хотіли
розповісти про наші тестові завдання
єдине що наостанок хочу сказати що
відповідно до процедур української
інституту розвитку освіти Наші тести
пройшли чотири види експертизи це
антидискримінаційна педагогічна Наукова
і психологічна тобто
у вас має бути найменша сумнівів щодо
фаховості цього інструменту так і Щодо
його застосування тому Закликаємо
якнайшвидше ним користуватися і робити
правильні висновки Нагадую що це був
другий вебінар перший вебінар був
присвячений
первинному діагностичному тестуванню з
української мови посилання до цього
вебінару будуть у під цим відео і також
ми ще плануємо третій вебінар але більше
до ближче до весни він буде
розрахований на вчителів початкової
школи будемо говорити про діагностичні
тести за курс
початкової школи
власне чому для вчителів початкової
школи тому що вони зможуть застосувати
цей інструмент
орієнтовно в травні для того щоб виявити
ті прогалини які були за курс 3-4 класу
але як я сказала такий вебінар буде дещо
пізніше Дуже дякую всім авторам які я
змогли сьогодні до нас долучитися ми
мали сьогодні проблеми із електрикою і
підключенням до інтернету але
Сподіваюся це не завадило нам вкласти
все що ми хотіли сказати і розповісти
про діагностичні тести дуже дякуємо за
увагу до скорость зустрічі
дякую вам